we've talked about how Wars get
started how do you hope the war in
Ukraine ends what are the ways to end
this war what are the ways to achieve
peace there to uh end the
the I would say
senseless death of young men as always
happens in
War I I'm sad to say I don't have a good
answer to that
um I I don't think there's any real
Prospect of a meaningful peace agreement
I think it's almost
impossible uh I I think the best you can
hope for uh at this point is it's some
some point the shooting stops you have a
ceasefire and then you have a frozen
conflict uh and that Frozen conflict uh
will not be highly stable uh and and uh
the uh ukrainians in the west will do
everything they can to weaken Russia's
position uh and the Russians will go to
Great Lengths to not only damage that
dysfunctional rum state that Ukraine
becomes but the Russians will go to
Great Lengths to seow dissension within
the alliance and uh and that includes in
terms of transatlantic relations so
you'll have this
continuing security competition between
Russia on one side and Ukraine and the
West on the other even when you get a
frozen
peace uh and um or you get a frozen
conflict and uh and and and the
potential for escalation there will be
great uh so I think this is a disaster
that's a very realist perspective let me
ask you sort of a the The Human Side of
it do you think there's some power to to
leader sitting down having a
conversation man to man leader to leader
about this there's there there is just a
lot of death
happening it seems that from a economic
perspective from a historic perspec from
a human perspective both nations are
losing is it possible for Vladimir
zalinski and and Vladimir Putin to sit
down and talk and
to uh figure out a way
where uh the security concerns are
addressed and both Nations can um
minimize the amount of suffering that's
happening and and and create a a path
towards future
flourishing I think the answer is no
even with uh United States involved
three people in the room well I think
you if the United States is involved the
answer is definitely no you have to get
the Americans out uh and then I I think
if you have zinski and Putin talking you
know you have a sliver of a chance there
the Americans
are a real problem look let's go back to
what happens right after the war starts
okay as I said before this is we're
talking March early April of 2022 the
war starts on February 24th
2022 and as I said to you uh the two
sides were negotiating in aan buul and
they were also uh negotiating through
Neftali Bennett and the Bennett track
and the Turkish track were operating
together I mean they were not at Cross
purposes at
all what
happened Bennett tells the story very
clearly that they had made significant
progress in reaching an agreement this
is zalinski on one side and Putin on the
other Bennett is talking in person to
both Putin and uh
zalinski and what happens to produce
failure the answer is the United States
and Britain get involved and tell
zalinsky to walk they tell zalinsky to
walk if they had come in and encouraged
zalinski to try to figure out a way with
Putin to shut this one down and worked
with Bennett and worked with erdogan mhm
we might have been able to shut the war
down then but it was the United
States well let me sort of uh push back
on that you're you're you're correct but
so United States paints this like um
picture that everybody's aligned so I
maybe you can correct me but I believe
in the power of individuals especially
individual leaders again whether it's
Biden or Trump or whoever goes into a
room and says in a way that's convincing
that no more NATO expansion
and actually just on a basic human
level ask the question of
why are we doing all this senseless
killing and look at the interest of one
Russia look at the interest of the other
Ukraine their interests are pretty
simple and say United States is going to
stay out of this we're not going to
expand NATO and say all that in a way
that's convincing which is NATO
expansion silly at this point china is
the big threat we're not going to do
this kind of uh conflict escalation with
Russia the Cold War is Over let's let's
uh normalize relations well let me just
embellish your argument okay thank
you did I need it if we say there's a
sliver of a chance that you can do this
and I do think there is a slier of a
chance let me just embellish your point
Thank you need all the help I can get
two things have to be done here in my
opinion one is uh Ukraine has to become
neutral and it has to completely sever
all security ties with the West
right it's not like uh you can say we're
not going to expand NATO to include
Ukraine but we're going to continue to
have some loose security arrangement
with with Ukraine none of that has to be
completely severed Ukraine has to be on
its own okay and number two Ukraine has
to accept the fact that the Russians are
going to keep the four oblas that
they've now Ann nexted and
Crimea right the Russians are not going
to give them
back and what you really want to do if
you're zalinski or who's ever running
Ukraine in this scenario that we're
positing
is you want to make sure the Russians
don't take another four oblas to include
AR and Odessa
right if I'm playing Putin's hand and
this war goes on I'm thinking about
taking four more
oblas I want to take about 43% of
Ukraine and an exit to Russia right and
I certainly want Odessa uh and I
certainly want harke and I I want the
two Bloss in between as well right
literally or as uh leverage in
negotiation no Ukraine neutrality I want
them literally uh I want to conquer them
literally uh but my point to you is if
we can begin to talk about cutting a
deal now you may be able to head that
kind of aggression off at the past in
other words you may be able to limit
Putin and Russia to annexing the 40
block L that they've now annexed plus
Crimea that's the best I think you can
hope for but the point is you have to
get the ukrainians to accept that you
have to get the ukrainians to accept
becoming a truly neutral State and
conceding that the Russians keep a big
chunk of territory it's about 23% of
Ukrainian territory that they've
annexed and I find it hard to imagine
any Ukrainian leader agreeing to that
well there there there could be more
nuanced things things like no military
involvement between the United States
and Ukraine but economic involvement
sort of uh financial
support So normalizing economic
relationships with Ukraine with Russia I
I think you could probably get away with
that I I think the the the tricky
question there that you would have to
answer is what about EU expansion right
and I think EU expansion is probably a
no no for the Russians because most
people don't recognize this but there is
a military Dimension built in to EU
expansion it's not purely an
economic uh Alliance uh or relationship
or institution whatever word you want to
use there's a military Dimension to that
and in the runup to the War uh actually
in the runup to the 2014 crisis when it
first broke out uh the Russians made it
clear they saw EU expansion as a
stalking horse for NATO expansion so EU
expansion is tricky but I I think your
point of close economic relations
between uh or healthy economic relations
to use a better term between Ukraine and
the West is possible I I I think the
Russians have a vested interest in if if
it's a neutral Ukraine they have a
vested interest in that Ukraine
flourishing but then then brings us back
to the territorial issue all right well
so do you believe it's possible for
individual human relations to counteract
the structural forces that you talk
about so meaning the
leaders being able to pick up the phone
and make agreements that are good for
Humanity as a whole and for their
individual nations in the long term I
think leadership matters here uh I mean
one of the real problems here is is that
there's no trust and uh on the Russian
side and that has to do with the Minsk
agreements um the uh uh the Minsk
agreements uh which were designed to
shut down the Civil
War uh in eastern Ukraine in the
donbas um really mattered to the
Russians and there were four players
involved in the uh uh the men's process
uh four main players Russia and Ukraine
of course and then Germany and
France and uh I believe the Russians
took the Minsk Accords seriously uh I
believe Putin took them very seriously
he wanted to shut down that
conflict uh and uh Angela Merkel
Francois Holland he was the French
leader and penko who was the Ukrainian
leader those were the three key players
besides Putin again and Holan from
France Merkel from Germany and penko
from Ukraine have all explicitly said
they were not seriously interested in
reaching an agreement in all of the
discussions with Putin they were
bamboozling him they were trying to
trick him so that they would buy time to
build up Ukraine's military uh Putin is
profoundly upset set about these
admissions by these three leaders he
believes he was fooled into thinking
that Mintz could work he believes that
he negotiated in good faith and they did
not and he believes that the level of
trust now between Russia uh and the West
is virtually zero as a result of this
experience over Minsk I only bring this
up because it cuts against your argument
that leaders could pick up the phone and
talk to each other and trust each other
at least somewhat uh to work out a
meaningful deal if you're Putin at this
point in time trusting the West is not
an idea that's going to be very
attractive at all in fact you're going
to distrust anything they say yeah
distrust anything the West say but there
is individual humans the way human
nature works is when you sit in the
cross from a person you can trust a
human being while still distrusting the
West I mean I I I believe in the power
of that I I think with the right leaders
you could sit down and talk like over
override the general structural distrust
of the West and say you know what I like
this guy or gal whatever I do hope
zilinski and Putin sit down together and
talk have multiple
talks just remember they were doing that
in March and the Americans came in and
the British came in yeah and they
scotched a potential
deal
well uh the other beautiful thing about
human nature there's forgiveness and
there's uh trying again when you're the
leader of a country in an anarchic
system you have to be very careful not
to let uh your trust in a foreign leader
take you too far because if that foreign
leader betrays you or betrays your trust
and stabs you in the back you could die
and again you want to remember that the
principal responsibility of any leader I
don't care what country it is is to
ensure the survival of their state and
that means that you know trust is only
going to buy you so much and when you've
already betrayed the trust of a leader
uh you really are not going to be able
to rely on trust very much to help you
moving forward now you disagree with
that I hope you're right and if they can
shut down the Ukraine Russia War uh it
would be wonderful if if I'm proved dead
wrong uh that would be wonderful news um
my my prediction that this war is going
to go on for a long time and
uh and end in an ugly way is a
prediction that I don't like at all so I
hope I'm
wrong